nach der entdeckung der
gravitationswellen geht es jetzt richtig
los auch das thema habt ihr euch wieder
über whatsapp gewünscht schon albert
einstein hatte die gravitationswellen im
jahr 1916 vorhergesagt doch bis sie zum
ersten mal nachgelesen werden sollten
dauerte es ganze 100 jahre
warum verformen gravitationswellen das
weltall und wie konnte man sie nach
einem jahrhundert endlich aufspüren und
was passiert damit in zukunft jetzt in
klicks und science fiction hat sich
willkommen
ja und wenn er auch über whatsapp und
die anderen messenger mitmachen wollt am
ende des videos erfragt wie das
funktioniert heute mal wieder fix sein
süppchen aus juli 2017 war es endlich
soweit der nobelpreis für physik ging an
drei gravitationswellen forscher aus den
usa
denn sie hatten jeweils mit ihren
experimenten und mit ihrer
grundlagenforschung zum ersten mal den
nachweis von gravitationswellen erbracht
rainer weiss kippt form und barry
bärisch haben tatsächlich gezeigt
einstand hatte recht übrigens gibt sein
könnte als executive producer von
intercell
und wirklich die messung von
gravitationswellen ist nicht nur für die
physik welt eine sensation
dazu rainer weis ein gebürtiger
deutscher ich betrachte das mehr als
eine sache die die arbeit von 1000
menschen anerkennt und tatsächlich an
diesem thema waren bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt sicherlich unzählige
forscherinnen und forscher weltweit dran
ich hätte sogar das weitaus mehr als
1000 forscherinnen und forscher dabei
besonders spannend ist die persönliche
geschichte von rainer weiss der
tatsächlich selbst diesen ja einen
unfassbar wichtigen augenblick verpasst
hat am 14 september 2015 0 54 51
amerikanischer ortszeit lage erstens
noch im bett und war zweitens im urlaub
weit weg von seinen beiden kilometer
langen detektoren die plötzlich
erzielten erst dachte er nur dass es ein
fehler war ein tolles signal von seinem
forschungsteam um zu testen ob die
datenauswertung auf sauber arbeitet doch
dann war klar dass das system nach einem
update für solch einen fehlalarm noch
gar nicht bereit war und das war der
große moment der von jetzt auf gleich
alles veränderte nach jahrzehntelanger
suche hatten sich gravitationswellen es
lassen ausgelöst durch den
zusammenschluss von zwei schwarzen
löchern wie immer in der wissenschaft
ist solch eine entdeckung noch deutlich
mehr wert wenn sie wiederholt werden
kann und tatsächlich auch folgende
messungen bestätigten den nachhall
solcher kollisionen dass dafür den
nobelpreis fertig war ja eigentlich
reine formsache zu seiner großartigen
karriere sagt reiter weiß heute wir
haben nicht groß über gravitationswellen
nachgedacht die technik war faszinierend
wir hatten solchen spaß dabei die zum
funktionieren zu bringen ein bisschen
wie kinder in einem großen sandkasten
ja es werden ja bei einem
gravitationswellen den sektor die
interferenzen zwischen zwei im 90 grad
winkel zueinander verlaufenden
laserstrahlen gemessen
wenn sie durch eine gravitationswellen
durchlaufen ändert sich jeweils die
raumzeit der beiden strahlen
unterschiedlich wenn sie dann
miteinander abgeglichen bilden sie
interferenz angefangen hat also alles
mit der relativitätstheorie von albert
einstein indem er die gravitationswellen
beschrieben hatte demnach produzieren
alle beschleunigten körper
gravitationswellen doch in den meisten
fällen sind sie viel zu schwach um sie
nachzuweisen angefangen beim start eines
autos bis hin zu einer sternexplosion am
ende ihrer lebenszeit die entstehenden
gravitationsfeld stauchen und strecken
raum und zeit etwa so wie ein stein den
man ins wasser wirft und der die
wasseroberfläche kreuze dazu muss man
wissen dass gravitation ein
relativistische effekte zugeschrieben
in der allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
große massen verzerren raum und zeit
unsere erde zum beispiel hinterlässt
eine beule im raum und zeit und in diese
bäume fallen wir auf die erde wir werden
also nicht durch eine kraft auf die erde
gezogen sondern durch die vertiefung die
sie in der raumzeit ferne wenn also
massen sich bewegen oder kollidieren
dann erzeugen sie dadurch keine delle
sondern eben wählen aber vor allem große
objekt geben alle erzeugen starke
gravitationsfeld schwarze löcher und
neutronensterne
wenn solche massen schnell genug
beschleunigt werden wird die raumzeit so
stark durch wirbelt dass die
gravitationswellen auch noch in größerer
entfernung aufzuspüren sind so wie eben
bei der kollision der beiden schwarzen
löcher im september 2015
wenn sich die wellen im weltall
ausbreiten wird alles was sie passieren
in einer richtung gedehnt und einer
anderen richtung zusammengedrückt eben
wie bei wellen doch selbst wenn die
gravitationswellen sehr stark sind
verformen sie das weltall nur minimal
der effekt ist eben nur extrem schwer
messbar einstein dachte jedenfalls
damals im leben nicht daran dass man
irgendwann in der lage sein
die witzigen veränderung zum essen die
diese welt gehören in diesem punkt ja da
sollte er sich dann doch getäuscht haben
der direktor des laser interferometer
gravitationswellen observatoriums liga
in den usa der 13 manche jedenfalls nach
dem ersten nachweis vor 400 jahren hatte
galileo ein teleskop auf den himmel
gerichtet ich glaube wir tun heute etwas
ähnlich wichtiges wir eröffnen eine neue
ära
denn durch die detektion von
gravitationswellen können wir jetzt ganz
andere dinge im weltall beobachten die
uns bisher verborgen geblieben sind und
schon bald wird noch ein viel
empfindlichere instrument dafür in
betrieb genommen das wird uns
wahrscheinlich täglich neue
gravitationswellen melden
die europäische weltraumagentur esa
plant nämlich den gravitationswellen
detektor lisa im weltraum er soll
zwischen erde und sonne gebaut werden
und zwar an dem punkt an dem sich die
kavitation der beiden gestirne auf der
erste test hatte wurde bereits
erfolgreich ausgesetzt das laser
interferometer space antenna system kurz
leiser wird auf drei satelliten bestehen
jeweils 2,5 millionen kilometer
voneinander entfernt sind beim lego
league die länge der arme bei 4
kilometer es wird also rund 600.000 mal
empfindlicher sein
bei einer entfernung von 2,5 millionen
kilometer ist dieser gravitationswellen
detector eben viel empfindlicher dass
sich die raumzeit auf solange entfernung
deutlicher aus der start des systems ist
für 2034 vorgesehen da können wir also
extrem gespannt sein wer als erstes
neues dazu zu allen anderen dem erfahren
wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei rezept oder den anderen
messengern wie instagram facebook
messenger oder telegramm dann erfahrt
ihr von mir vor allen andern vom
neuesten video täglich garantiert ihr
könnt doch direkt über mich in der
redaktion von links und mitmachen und
mitbestimmen was hier wirklich passiert
und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein
kleines goodie einfach hier klicken und
natürlich nicht das abo mit der
vergessen
hier geht es weiter fraglich mit stephen
hawkings letzte arbeit veröffentlicht
ansonsten bis dann bleibt